[Music]
there was a sort of synergy of we're
looking to do something interesting in
VR and we've got this division and
you're looking to sort of bring you know
what sense you have of storytelling with
him and put that into the context that
we are you can for the first time as a
player feel like you are in a movie
that's a really good word for it we want
you to take off the gear and still feel
unsettled
whilst working with Ubisoft we stumbled
across some fascinating research that
had begun in the late 90s essentially
neuro scientists had figured out a way
to upload brain data trauma emotional
emotions memories to the digital space
now we've gone and taken the next
logical step and really some reason
we've recreated in virtual reality once
that's set up in time so we'd like money
to come and join us and experience the
walther test case for yourself we don't
[Music]
[Music]
what you were experiencing is a recorded
consciousness it's not like watching a
movie so no matter how real it may seem
it can't hurt you
you were completely safe you were
completely safe
[Applause]